[Musique]
en ce début de janvier 2022 la pandémie
de covè 19 continue à bouleverser les
habitudes des français depuis ce 3
janvier il est interdit de consommer de
boue dans les bars et les restaurants il
règle à appliquer pendant trois semaines
autre règle entrée en vigueur le 3
janvier le retour du télétravail est
obligatoire trois jours dans les
entreprises qui peuvent le mettre en
place et une semaine pour s'organiser ce
mois de janvier c'est aussi celui d'un
anniversaire l'euro à 20 ans entré en
vigueur le 1er janvier 2001 la monnaie
européenne concerne aujourd'hui 19 pays
un premier vol inaugural prévue pour
2025 depuis le centre spatial de kourou
en guyane ollo josas sérieux space
services pons syrie justin un lanceur
spatial réutilisable
la 80e édition du paris-nice partira de
mantes la ville depuis treize ans le
départ de la course au soleil se joue
dans le département la deuxième étape
s'élancera depuis auffargis rendez vous
le 6 mars prochain
longtemps le protégé de louis xiv
molière est né il ya 400 ans la ville de
versailles c'est la mort à tout au long
de l'année le dramaturge français
[Musique]